the gyro can experience nomads time when
we got really really really really
really high and we went to see one of
your professors one of your greatest
sing sing musicals yes I do that was
that was a wonderful night it was out it
was a while I love that kind of stuff we
were so I couldn't walk fast no me
neither like the real kind well I knew I
knew how to walk but I wasn't totally
sure I could keep doing it I never I
never smoked weed and but when I do it
to you it's like I got high one time I
was with patty Jenkins we were in a
[ __ ] Atlantic City and we'd and
swimming and I smoked weed and I didn't
I was not a weed smoker and you swam in
the water at the ocean
[ __ ] you at night dude you're doing huge
waves I lost Mike we lost the car keys
and we're looking everywhere dude
everywhere and two hours later I sit
down on the curb son my BOB just tired
we don't worry too much Pat looks at me
and she goes Brian yeah open your hand
please of course it was
[Applause]